[Applaudissements]
oui ça va arriver on en a pour une 45e
deux minutes
c'est une mise pour calais l'image ses
limites en dessous de boli 6 1 on y va
il attendait je vais regarder leur bail
7h15 les gars sont parties illégales
allez on regarde jouer là venez avec moi
même ça mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel
mais pourquoi mais qui doit dans ces
sujets si c'est toi c'est toi c'est toi
le coupable
vas-y alors c'est lui le coupable
regardez le alors il va le lancer vas-y
mon autre nombreux téléspectateurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui qu'il fallait y penser au début mais
l'histoire est vraie à l'arc et tout ça
pour ça voilà c'est lui le responsable
voilà vous pouvez lui écrire je vais
vous donner son adresse je vous donner
sa carte merci au mieux 2 rien merci
d'être passé
salut tu penses falloir lakota